[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo monitorear aviones se ha
vuelto algo muy común por estos días y
un tema del que se habla mucho en redes
sociales y medios de comunicación esto
tiene que ver por un lado con la gran
expectativa que generó el vuelo de la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi a
taiwán en medio de las amenazas de china
y por otro lado en la indignación que
han despertado varias celebridades
mundiales después de que se revelara que
utilizaron sus jets privados para hacer
un sinnúmero de viajes cortos y
generando toneladas de emisiones de
carbono de quienes se trata en esta
emisión de revistas digitales contamos
empezando
el vuelo en el que la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de eeuu nancy
pelosi se trasladó hacia taiwán fue el
más rastreado de todos los tiempos según
reportó flight reiter 24 un sitio web
que muestra información en tiempo real
sobre el tráfico aéreo de acuerdo con
los responsables de la página el
trayecto del spar 19 cómo se identifica
el vuelo llegó a ser visualizado por
casi 3 millones de personas desde que
despegó de malasia y al momento de
aterrizar en taipei la capital taiwanesa
estaba siendo rastreado por más de 700
8000 personas en todo el mundo la masiva
atención sobre este viaje se debía a las
insinuaciones de usuarios en redes
sociales quienes sin argumentos se
referían a la posibilidad de que el
avión pudiera ser derribado por china
cuyo gobierno advirtió consecuencias si
pelos y pisaba suelo taiwanés
flight ryder 24 es tal vez el sitio más
popular para monitorear vuelos en vivo
pero no es el único
antes de pelosi a taiwán el trayecto más
rastreado por esta página había sido el
del opositor ruso alexéi navalni más de
550.000 personas vigilaban su viaje
cuando decidió regresar a su país desde
alemania donde se recuperaba después de
supuestamente haber sido envenenado esta
función es posible gracias a una
tecnología en las aeronaves conocida
como sistema de vigilancia dependiente
autonómica o a dsb por sus siglas en
inglés y que en términos simples permite
a los aviones transmitir sus ubicaciones
a una especie de receptores conectados
con páginas como flight 'radar 24 según
explica el diario británico the guardian
para optimizar su funcionamiento este
sitio web se apoya en herramientas del
gobierno estadounidense lo que lo obliga
a cumplir con varias reglas para no
mostrar la ubicación de cierto tipo de
vuelos
para cubrir esta brecha existe otra
página llamada heidi es bi exchange y
cuya tecnología se utilizó recientemente
para exponer las celebridades que han
hecho un uso bastante recurrente de sus
aviones privados lo que ha tenido un
impacto desproporcionado en el medio
ambiente por ello se han ganado el apodo
de criminales climáticos la polémica
estalló a mediados de julio cuando una
cuenta en twitter llamada celebrity jets
que reporta los vuelos realizados por
famosos reveló que la menor de las
kardashians kylie jenner realizó un
viaje en avión que sólo duró tres
minutos la indignación creció cuando
esta joven publicó en su cuenta de
instagram una fotografía junto a su
esposo en la que se ven dos jets y con
un comentario que dice quieres tomar el
mío o el tuyo
basándose en estos datos la empresa de
marketing art realizó un ranking con los
mayores infractores
la compañía señala que esta lista no es
concluyente ya que no hay forma de saber
si los dueños de estos jets estuvieron
en todos los vuelos registrados pero que
el propósito era resaltar el impacto
dañino del uso de aviones privados y
este es el resultado veamos mientras que
con sus acciones diarias una persona
promedio emite unas 7 toneladas de co2
al año es decir dióxido de carbono que
es una de las principales causas del
calentamiento global el informe reveló
que en lo que va del año sólo en vuelos
la cantante taylor swift que es la
primera en la lista produjo más de 8 mil
toneladas de co2 le siguen el boxeador
floyd mayweather con más de 7 mil
toneladas el rapero jay sí con más de 6
mil 900 el beisbolista alex rodríguez
con más de 5 mil 300 y el intérprete de
música country blake shelton con 4 mil
por supuesto las reacciones no se
hicieron esperar e internet se llenó no
solo de comentarios que condenaron el
estilo de vida de estas celebridades
sino que también hubo espacio para el
humor como esta publicación que ver a
continuación en twitter que sugería que
así se vería una carrera entre taylor
swift kylie jenner y kim kardashian para
ver quién llega primero a comprar un
café en un starbucks o que así se
transportaba a taylor swift en medio de
la noche para ir al baño los dejamos con
algunos de los memes más populares sin
dejar de recordarles que el cuidado del
medio ambiente es un tema muy serio
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www